Ukraine's president of Vladimir
zielinski continues his series of
European visits he's now in the UK
meeting with prime minister Rishi sinak
the two leaders I've been outside's
official country residence of checkers
Britain is expected to confirm supplies
of air defense systems and long-range
attack drones to Kiev to defend itself
against Russian attacks last week the UK
became the first country to supply
Ukraine with long-range cruise missiles
we're going to go live now to Nadine
Baba in London this wasn't as I
understand it publicly revealed that he
was going to make this trip to the UK
what's he hoping to achieve particularly
in the light of this offer from the UK
foreign
well Rob this is a visit that comes off
the back of President zielinski visiting
Germany and France and just ahead of his
uh arrival here in the UK he put out a
tweet saying that the UK is a leader
when it comes to expanding our
capabilities on the ground and in the
air and then just minutes later an
announcement by the UK government that
it was going to be providing Ukraine
with hundreds more air defense missiles
and interestingly hundreds of attack
drones which have a range of around 200
kilometers so something that a lot of
analysts are saying could be very
important in actually taking out supply
routes and stocks
um the um the Ukrainian president was
here back in February he addressed both
houses of Parliament here he met with
King Charles and then just last week the
UK said it was going to be the first
country to supply Ukraine with a
long-range cruise missiles Storm Shadow
missiles and they have the capability of
capability of reaching well beyond the
front lines Russia has reacted on Monday
to all of this saying that it has an
extremely negative view of the UK's
pledges of more military aid but that
the Kremlin doesn't believe that it will
actually change the outcome of the
conflict something else that Russia will
take a dim view of is President
zielinski's continued drive to try to
speed up his Western allies approving
membership of NATO for Ukraine he wants
that to be greenlighted at a summit in
July and we know that that's something
that he's been talking to Rishi sunac
the Prime Minister about in the last
hour or so around 55 kilometers north
west of here there have been warm words
between the two of course Lots were made
lots was made of President zielinski's
friendship with president with prime
minister Boris Johnson Rishi sunak very
keen for his own position as well to
show people that the but he stands
firmly behind Ukraine in the conflict
Nadeem thank you Nadeem Baba in London